there's just been a report that Israel
has announced an invasion of Gaza well
you know I negotiated the last ceasefire
exactly who is no longer the president
but to be fair this was November of 2012
rockets were raining down on Israel we
had an internal debate that I recount in
the book about whether or not the United
States should get so actively involved
in trying to prevent what at that point
was the calling up reserves for a
potential invasion of Gaza I thought we
should I made that case to the president
I flew from Cambodia to Israel I met
with the Prime Minister Netanyahu the
internal security cabinet and you know
made the case and they were receptive to
that case that we wanted to head off an
invasion they were within 48 hours of
invading and we had a a set of
principles that the Israelis wanted
Hamas to agree to and it was the first
test for Morsi so I did go to Cairo
negotiated with him personally because
we had to go through literally word by
word unlike other circumstances he had a
relationship with Hamas well general
Sisi does not have that kind of relation
no he doesn't
he doesn't but but Morsi had never done
anything like this before and so it was
new territory for him he had to persuade
Hamas leaders who he didn't know that
well but who obviously they thought well
he's a Muslim Brotherhood president
they're closely connected and he was
able to do that and we set an arbitrary
time for the ceasefire and it held until
you know this month in this case there
there are big differences obviously the
leadership of Egypt has changed the
stockpiling of weapons and more
effective missiles and now even drones
has changed so that's the threat and
they aren't dome that's coming to me I
well they aren't dome was effective the
last time - but it's proven to be even
more so because the numbers of missiles
have increased and I think that Israel's
is that with these stockpiles of weapons
that are now in Gaza that it would be
difficult to get a reliable ceasefire no
Egypt
you know Egypt did announce a ceasefire
Israel immediately said yes Hamas said
no and so that's where the space is not
being seen you support the Israelis in
invading Gaza you know I think the is an
easy question no it's not an easy
question because I would prefer not
that's why I flew from Cambodia to try
to prevent an invasion we have enough to
prevent an invasion well I don't know
the answer to that because I'm not on
the inside I know that there's been a
lot of phone calls and a lot of outreach
and working with Arabs and others to try
to influence Hamas and to try to get
them to stand down Hamas may feel like
they're totally cornered they've got
Egypt under CC on one side they've got
Israel not willing to and I don't blame
them at all for suffering missiles and
so Hamas may feel like they have nothing
to lose